papa je suis d'accord avec un petit mot
on va bien est sorti de prison après un
mois et demi il a fait un arrêt
cardiaque en prison pour brut je vais
vous raconter une histoire de gaël une
française de 31 ans qui a grandi à
angers elle a un fils mohamed
mais lui est né loin de la france ce
même qui m'aiment pas gaël n'a pas vu
son père depuis des années et lui ne
comprend toujours pas comment sa fille a
pu en arriver là
brad est incrédule tu le crois pas je
crois pas ça vous a même pas traversé
l'esprit que vous pourriez peut-être la
renier à cause de ce départ là pour
aider ma fille ah non non non c'est
impossible du sepa
c'est c'est absolument impossible
et m'a demandé mille fois pardon une
écoute moi j'ai rien n'est pardonné cet
avis bon après je suis pas touché je
suis ton père
[Musique]
gaël est née en 1989 à angers dans une
famille de quatre enfants sa mère
jacqueline travail à la poste et son
père albert dans les télécoms
[Musique]
une gamine je dirais comme comme plein
d'autres première bougie le 14 juillet
90 ans je m'en souviens je m'en souviens
bien parce que c'est même si la marée
basse c'est quasiment laquelle a fait
ses premiers pas d'ailleurs je m'en
souviens comme si c'était hier qu'il a
on voit la petite fille à son papa
renard qui s'était invité avant sur la
terrasse il fait nuit et toute contente
tout qu'ils suite on va trouver galles
dans un truc et qu'elle adore elle a
fait de la gym les 16 doigts dans les
yeux les yeux qui brillent
gaël était petit
sans problème il a poussé la poussine
fonctionne elle n'était pas compliqué
puisque l'arrêté normal pour son bts et
les parties pendant deux mois au pérou à
lima
elle était attiré par l'étranger de
toute manière elle voulait et voulait
travailler les tranchées et voulait
voulait vivre sa vie à l'étranger pour
rencontrer des gens pour rencontrer
d'autres cultures elle était très
ouverte par rapport à ça en 2010 à l'âge
de 21 ans elle rencontre faty un
tunisien dont elle tombe rapidement
amoureuse et avec qui elle se pacsent
deux ans plus tard en galets la
rencontre et ont contré satie fin 2010
sont soumis en ménage s'est rapidement
dans l'appartement qu'on louait nous
pour pour gaël et
donc il est venu rapidement la maison
quand je les ai vus jusque là lui
c'était quelqu'un bon plus vieux qu'elle
allait 15 ans de plus musulman je savais
mais qui nous a jamais pris la tête avec
ça j'ai bossé avec lui il est
électricien et c'est un mec franchement
il alors dans les mains un accord il
n'était pas de tout faire
on savait qu'il avait un mal vivre en
france parce qu'il est en butte à
beaucoup de choses telles que le
contrôle au faciès tels que la
difficulté d'avoir un job correspondant
à ces qualifications et en fait tout
bascule en juillet 2015
faty égale annonce à albert qu'ils vont
un mariage en tunisie mais en réalité
ils sont partis en irak pour rejoindre
l'état islamique
brad est incrédule tout le crois pas tu
le crois pas c'est c'est pas c'est pas
possible c'est non tu crois pas non moi
j'ai mis j'ai mis un sacré bouton pour
le croire pour se dire oui oui
effectivement on les parties - pour moi
à l'époque c'était tellement simple les
gens qui partaient la barre c'était déjà
un des gens qui étaient d'origine
d'origine arabe
je vais prendre un raccourci mais c'est
volontaire c'était des racailles du 9-3
quoi ces eaux se rende compte mon bien
après que c'était loin de tout ça quoi
ça pourrait pas concerné des gens
dd je dirais des français moyens com
comment accorder des gens dont je fais
partie ça c'était des gens pour être
pour être de radicaliser fallait des
gens et d'un milieu musulman c'est ma
réflexion s'est éteint au moment où elle
apprend à son père qu'elle est en irak
elle lui annonce sa conversion à l'islam
quand on l'a su et nous a dit que ça
faisait trois ans qu'elles étaient
converties donc essayez converti en 2012
quoi mais bon il me l'avait nous l'avait
pas dit qu'on sait pas ce qu'est ce
converti sous pack initial n'était pas
le fait d'être au service à la limite si
on n'avait pas grand chose à faire c'est
la liberté de chacun par rapport à son
amant chen mo tic
j'étais levée d'un milieu très très
catho
mais que ma fille se convertissaient
leurs héros du mal vous voyez absolument
aucun inconvénient c'était son choix
il est qu'après pas confondre g
la religion musulmane et puis là je sais
c'est des choses qui n'ont par contre va
voir tron la dernière fois que j'ai vu
c'est au mois d'avril wave 3 avril avril
donc ça fait 55 ans et demi 3
[Musique]
et après pendant toute cette période où
elle était au sein de l'état islamique
est ce que vous aviez des nouvelles
d'elle régulièrement on avait des
nouvelles très d'une façon très très
très simple dès le début j'ai dit coûte
actuellement une seule chose quoi cas
nous nous voyons un petit message de
temps en temps pour qu'on sache que tu
es pas morte
et puis c'est tout quoi est ce qu'elle
vous a parlé des activités qu'elle a pu
faire au sein de l'état islamique
une fois qu'elle était sur place et me
dit avoir travaillé dans un magasin de
vêtements
ça peut durer bien longtemps ça va durer
quelques mois et ensuite bon ils ont
quitté rapidement mossoul au bout de six
mois il était parti et elle elle était
elle était à la maison quand il faisait
faisait rien de particulier elle n'est
pas elle n'est pas d'activité spécifique
qu'est ce qu'elle vous disais ouais à
l'époque albert parle fréquemment à gaël
mais sa fille c'est qu'elle est
surveillé tous les messages que j'avais
je jeu les renvoyer en copie à la dgsi
et le savez toute façon c'était clair
que par rapport à ça donc ils ne savent
qu'on avait été était était vraiment
réduits au strict minimum
je suis contre complètement à la
radicalisation je suis anti des shows au
fond et jeu cachera rien de ce qui est
de ce qui se passe voilà elle vous
parlez pas du tout deux des exactions de
l'état islamique
non non vous parliez pas avec elle des
attentats une armée commis en trente ans
non les attentats ont été commis en
europe ce qu'elle disait oui bon je suis
pas d'accord mais si tu savais pas parce
qu'ils font ici et lisez mais la
commission ici tu des femmes et des
enfants et personne ne sait on avait
autre chose de plus important à
maintenir on avait un lien beaucoup plus
important à se maintenir que de parler
tout ça c'était pas su pas pour moi ton
parle pas par téléphone ça on vous le
plus important c'était de garder ce lire
absolument ouais ouais ouais c'était
très égoïste mais mais moi l'important à
ce moment là on va essayer de garder le
lien avec ma fille
en janvier 2019 gaye elle accouche d'un
petit garçon qui s'appelle mohamed
trois mois plus tard elle fuit les
dernières heures de l'état islamique
pendant la bataille de barousse qui
marque la fin territoriale de dèche en
syrie et en irak
ma fille fait partie des derniers à
avoir quitté bagouzes pour une simple
raison la quitter barrows avec un bébé
de deux mois sur sur le dos quoi c'était
entre les extrémistes de l'état
islamique et lecture d'un côté et les
forces de bachar de côté
deux côtés du fleuve qui les a lus mais
quoi ils ont séparé ces là d un paquet
laquelle a vu son compagnon après son
arrestation par les forces kurdes
gaël est emmenée avec son bébé mohamed
dans un camp où sont détenus les femmes
et les enfants de l'état islamique
et quelques mois plus tard albert reçoit
les premières images de son petit fils
fait plaisir de voir ce genre de vidéos
nuit et je voulais pas ça nuit à donc je
suis content de le voir après de voir
dans ce qu en bresse et c'est
complètement autre chose qu'en guise et
c'est qu'il soit avec nous parce que
parce qu'il n'a rien à faire dans la
rencontre la moins les conditions de vie
sont ces notables
c'est mon oeuvre côté gaël parle souvent
à son père des conditions de vie très
difficiles dans le camp particulièrement
à cause de la situation sanitaire et du
manque d'eau potable
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète le plus dans
le camp pour votre petit fils notamment
en faut qu'ils sortent faut qu'ils
sortent le plus vite possible c'est pas
il peut pas rester c'est trop dangereux
un gamin qui peut pas l'empêcher de
mettre de mettre les doigts la bouche le
sol le sol et pourris ils ont toutes les
maladies possibles ils ont tous la
diarrhée faut pas rester là-bas c'est
pas c'est absolument impossible
j'ai plus chiffre exact c'est 300 gamins
qui sont morts l'année dernière
[Musique]
c'est le seul petit fils que cogite cetc
beaucoup d'amoureux donné beaucoup
d'amour à recevoir aussi c'est le cadeau
que la vie nous fait alors qu'on
n'espérait plus con et puis il est loin
il lui grandi et conduit loin nous on a
beaucoup d'amour a eut donné beaucoup de
confort à lui donner aussi parce que
parce que vous avez les moyens de lui
donner de lui procurer ce kung fu et on
peut pas
ma fille voulait se baigner ici on
laisse baigner avec elle ici un tous les
deux elle adorait mais beaucoup je crois
bon après c'est un peu dangereux parce
qu'il ya quelques rochers mais bon faire
attention
moi j'aimerais bien ici avec mon petit
fils dans quelques années quand il sera
un peu plus grand nez à nez avec lui si
moi je peux encore ouais mais on me
baigner avec lui ici là ce serait ce
serait génial
oui j'ai peur que mon petit fils tu vois
jamais singes ou ouais ouais j'ai peur
de ne pas pouvoir partager ça et plus à
jour je pose beaucoup de question de
savoir comment lui expliquer tout ça
comment expliquer que son pays la france
l'a laissé et quand il était bébé quand
il était tout petit quand il avait
aucune défense ou qu'on l'a laissé sans
rien sans penser le rapatrier albert se
bat depuis plusieurs mois pour que sa
fille et son petit fils soient rapatriés
et jugé en france mais le gouvernement
français mais pas officiellement
favorable à ces retours il n'y a eu que
quelques femmes et enfants de djihadiste
français qui ont pu rentrer jusqu'à
maintenant
et ces rapatriements se font à chaque
fois au cas par cas et très discrètement
vous savez que si elle rentre en france
si à les rapatrier elle risque d'aller
en prison pendant longtemps connaissait
pas guéri ses livres à lire oui mais
c'est ce que j'ai là par rapport à ça il
faut être client il faut il faut qu'il y
ait un procès faute il soit jugé
moi je fais pas d'angélisme c'est pas
c'est pas du tout ça c'est le droit le
droit justice c'est ça c'est qu'ils
seraient jugés mais qui est loin qu'elle
ait droit à un procès
et qu'ils soient jugés par rapport à ce
qu'il a fait pour ce qu'elle a fait ou
pas fini il faut que les séjourna
s'explique sur comment comment et
pourquoi ils sont partis ça vous a même
pas traversé l'esprit que vous pourriez
peut-être la renier à cause de ce départ
la corogne et ma fille ah non non non
c'est impossible tu sais pas c'est c'est
absolument impossible mans et m'a
demandé mille fois pardon je les écoute
moi j'ai rien n'est pardonné cet avis
bon après je suis pas trop j'ai je suis
je suis ton père je suis pas tranché je
sais par ce n'est qu' un jour ou l'autre
fille risque d'être avec elle et puis
voilà il faut que j'arrive à la
comprendre pour l'instant je comprends
pas tout donc j'arrive pas à expliquer
comment comment est ce que une
une fille comme ça puisse dévié vers
gaza pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi c'est
possible en fait c'est qu'est ce qu'on
est capable de faire en france parce que
ce qui va et ce qui m'importe
pour que ça ne se reproduise mans pour
qu'il n'y ait pas une dmla elle en fait
enfin d'autres il n'est pas neutre